important by what i've heard you say to
senator inhofe and senator fisher
about our nuclear triad and our nuclear
deterrent and with senator fisher in
particular about the ground-based
strategic deterrent replacement for the
minuteman iii
i do want to get a little more specific
about that because it's 50 years old
and we've seen problems with structural
fatigue and water intrusion and decayed
wiring
the gao has warned that we could lose
confidence in the fleet by
2026 a mere five years from now congress
has fully funded
the gbsd its replacement system and both
military and civilian leaders
have consistently warned that the
service life extension of the minuteman
3 is no longer an option
given that we have until recent years
put off nuclear modernization for so
long and the threats rising with china's
crash nuclear buildup
and russia's unconstrained tactical
weapon inventory dr hicks i wanted to
know if you will fully commit
to deploy the deployment of the gbsd on
its planned
schedule senator uh i'll say again that
i
believe the triad has been a bedrock for
american security and i am a
big believer in the value of the nuclear
deterrent what i can't say today
and until uh i have an opportunity if
i'm confirmed to get in
and understand the state just as you are
describing the
the the state of the various likes of
the triad in this case
the state of the land-based component
it's difficult for me to
assess exactly what the timeline and the
margin
if you will is and also the technical
feasibility issues not just resource
issues but technical feasibility issues
but what i can promise is i am committed
to a modernized
qualitatively effective deterrent
and if confirmed i'd be happy to work
with members here
on a discussion around what we're seeing
and what those timelines look like and
making sure that the fy 22 budget
um pushes forward the president's
commitment
to that nuclear deterrent at the same
time
that it's promoting america's
non-proliferation agenda
uh that commitment
uh to the deterrent includes the
ground-based leg of the turret
correct yes senator i believe that
our deterrent is strongest as a triad i
i understand that there will be
a re-look as there is in every
administration at uh the various aspects
of nuclear policy
and modernization i think that's
appropriate the trump administration did
that as well
um but if you're asking my personal view
my view is that the
we are the triad has served us very well
it has created stability
and it has a value and uh i can
understand your hesitation
to make the commitment of the deployment
on time
given the pentagon's long history of
many programs running
over time and over budget so let's
divide the reasons uh in half why you
wouldn't make that commitment one is the
policy reason that some
in the administration some of the
democratic party don't want to modernize
uh the missile leg of triad and then
there's all the concerns about
as you say the technical feasibility
where the program is it's financing and
so forth
is it the second concern that you have
that
causes you to hesitate towards making
commitment towards on-time delivery as
opposed to the first the ideological
or the policy one senator as a
nominee for
deputy secretary of defense i i probably
think myself mostly in the former
category in general yes i would be very
much focused on the viability
of the programming element of this
and i would be in support of the
secretary of course on the major policy
issues regarding nuclear posture where
he seeks my advice
but as i as i said in my opening
statement i think
my job is to make sure we can execute on
the president's
direction and on secretary austin's
direction
okay well what uh if confirmed i
certainly hope that will be a very top
priority to make sure all those
programmatic
uh issues um permit for the on-time
deployment of something critical or
national security
dr hicks you suggested something your
answer that i want to touch on as well
about a posture review will the bible
administration conduct a nuclear posture
review as has been the custom for the
last several
new presidential administrations senator
cotton
that is my understanding i i i don't
because i'm not inside the
administration i don't know
uh the status of that but it is my
understanding that there is an intention
to review
nuclear posture as well as of course
overall defense strategy
the latter part is a congressionally
mandated requirement
thank you one final question like all
administrations in the nuclear age to
include the obama administration will
the
uh biden administration decline to adopt
a no first use policy for nuclear
weapons
senator i can't speak to uh how the bind
administration might ultimately
come through its policy assessments uh
with regard to either nuclear
declaratory policy or other issues
um i have been on the record in the past
as not being
i don't believe no first use policy
isn't
is necessarily in the best interest of
the united states but those will be
decisions
ultimately made of course by the
president well thank you i hope you'll
be a vocal uh
voice for that and that people will
listen to you
thank you senator cotton now via webex
senator
gillibrand thank you mr chairman
um and thank you so much uh doctor for
being here
um i want to continue along the line of
argument that i listened to from senator
blumenthal
and you did say that you've reviewed the
fort hood investigative report
in that report there was a significant
recommendation
and it said that commander negligence at
fort hood
fostered a culture of violent crime
sexual assault and harassment
investigators provided a solution quote
to ensure objectivity and fairness the
sexual harassment assault response
or sharp program should operate
independent from local commands
and their legal advisors dr hicks
uh do you think that if local commanders
are not trusted to oversee sharp
that they should still get to decide
which sexual assaults and complex
criminal cases
should go forward to be prosecuted
senator gillibrand let me just first
thank you for your leadership in general
on this
issue as the fort hood report makes very
clear even just in the
one excerpt you've given this isn't an a
problem that doesn't appear to be
um getting any better um and we need to
be really
open i think on the solutions the levers
that will actually make a difference
um i am not a legal expert i
i can't speak to the specifics of how
the department
at this point you know without being in
the department
how the department ought to move forward
on those recommendations and
in particular on the accountability side
um prosecution and accountability side
but what i can say is that to the extent
that secretary austin
um uh is uh involving me
in decisions relating to encountering
sexual assault and harassment in the
military
that i'm very open to ideas even if they
include
um removing uh the commander from from
that
prosecution chain and the purpose of
that
would be to give the prosecution to
trained military prosecutors
who have had time to develop expertise
in criminal law
because right now fewer cases are
proceeding to trial and fewer cases are
ending in conviction
and so as a result we've seen a
lessening of people's faith in the
system
and the one recommendation that
survivors and
legal expert and advocates have
recommended is allowing the
professionalization of the prosecution
of major crimes
uh that have um jail time of more than a
year
and so that's why this is the
recommendation and
for your benefit we've put forward
pretty much every other
recommendation that the dod has
supported and turned it into law
and they have not changed these outcomes
um and the second thing that doesn't
seem to matter is whether a secretary of
defense takes this seriously or not
because
every single one of them has said
they've taken it seriously
from dick cheney on and so promises
empty promises are something that i hope
the biden administration does not
tolerate
and i would like your commitment that
you will really focus on this issue
to make sure that we get to the right
results where we can have
a military justice system that is worthy
of the sacrifices that the men and
women in our services make every single
day
senator you have that commitment okay
um i'd like to address now issues of
cyber security
last month it came to light that russia
had created a back door
into computers of at least 250 agencies
for nine months and possibly still
they've been able to monitor
computer activity and steal data that
has come
uh to our attention so
um a private company fire eye brought
that to our attention
not the dod this comes only after
two years that our cyber posture review
found that we've had difficulties
with dod cyberspace operations ability
to prevent malign activity from our
adversaries
now we've had several hearings on this
and we've had lots of proposed
changes one proposal is to increase the
role of the national
guard so that cyber security experts can
maintain their day jobs while also
serving the country
do you think this is a tool that could
be useful for this problem
senator i think the national guard can
bring
specialized capabilities in exactly
these types of areas where the
commercial sector
to your point about fireeye where the
commercial sector is sometimes out in
front
of the federal government so it does
seem to be at first glance that the
national guard could be helpful in this
area
last i wanted to touch on diversity
recently the dod released a 2017 survey
that showed 24.4 percent
of active duty minority service members
experienced harassment or discrimination
but only 26 percent reported their
experience to the
equal opportunity program only 16
of reports led to punishment of the
perpetrator and 10
somehow led to punishment of the
reporter while interviewing
um anthony brown last july you stated
the military is a quote engine to
counter racism
with statistics like this do you think
that engine is actually working and
would you agree that service members
should have the same
ability to report discrimination without
reprisal as a civilian dod
employee senator i hesitate to get into
specific recommendations related to
ucmj or or other legal matters
if confirmed i would absolutely want to
speak to the career lawyers
um to understand what the implications
are but to your general point
i think it is crystal clear that the
military has
not undertaken insufficient efforts on
diversity equity and inclusion
um and that we have a major leadership
challenge quite frankly we have a
problem on the prevention side and we
clearly have a problem
on holding folks accountable whether
it's sexual harassment and assault or
it's
dei related issues more broadly and i am
committed to making sure we make
genuine progress i know it's difficult
to hear
nominee after nominee come up and say
that but you have my commitment and i
would look forward to working with you
on both sets of the both of these sets
of issues
thank you thank you senator gillibrand
and uh via webex senator
rounds thank you mr chairman
um dr hicks thank you for your years of
service
um and and the work that you've done in
national security issues i want to thank
you for your willingness to serve once
again in such
an important position i enjoyed our
phone call last week and
i want you to know that i intend to
support your nomination
i do have a couple of questions that i'd
like to go through with you specifically
with regard to our
our dod cyber strategy which had been
published back in december of 2018 which
charges the dod to defend the forward
shape the day-to-day competition and
prepare for war
the united states cyber command has
demonstrated successful instances of
defend
forward in securing the 2018
and 2020 elections what are your views
on the defend
forward shape the day-to-day competition
and prepare for war concepts
to deter and disrupt russia and china
in cyberspace senator first thank you
very much for your um
your support of my nomination um
i have had an opportunity at different
periods in the last several years
to get a little more information on
what's behind defend forward i would say
based on the
briefings that i have had i am
supportive of the approach
i think if confirmed what i would like
to understand better is exactly how the
authorities
are being executed what kind of
oversight is
involved how we are consulting with
allies and partners
whose systems we might operate on i
think those are very
important questions for civilian policy
makers
to be engaged on but in general i
believe
that we have had to become
much more forward leaning in our
approach and i also think congress has
an
uh critical role to play here in terms
of authorities
and i would want to understand better
again how it's being executed today
to engage in a dialogue about what is
the appropriate role
for congress and for civilians uh
policymakers in the executive branch
i'm also very pleased by the progress
that we've made enabling cybercom
to rapidly conduct cyber effects
operations to include
offensive cyber operations can you tell
the american people
why this is so important to our national
defense i think it's important that the
public understand
that that we've got challenges with
people attacking us
but we have to be in a position to offer
offensive cyber operations even when
we're not
in an identified conflict
yes senator i think one of the major
challenges about thinking through
uh competition or or confrontations in
cyberspace is that the
classic definitions of what is offense
and what what is defense are very
blurred um and so it is
challenging to use the kind of
constructs we've thought of
uh in a terrestrial sense in cyberspace
what i would say to your point is the
way in which
adversaries can come at our systems and
the recent
russian hacks to include through solar
winds demonstrated this
is they can live in our systems for some
time
they can undertake espionage extract
information and then can um
turn in many cases onto what we would
think of as
offensive approaches in order for the
u.s to
to prevent that and deter that it
also sometimes has to defend forward
that is to say it has to be um living in
systems so that it has the warning the
intel indicators and warning um to know
that an attack
is imminent and that's where this
offensive piece becomes important
exactly and not only that but it also
provides us with advanced warning about
the types of tactics
that might very well be used because if
they're using those tactics
in other countries in advance they may
very well be using the same tactics
when it comes to trying to get into our
systems as well
but as we discussed during our call
there was an
effort in the last administration to end
the cybercom
nsa dual hack again i've been watching
this issue for a number of years now and
i'm
really concerned by that i had
originally come in thinking that and it
would be appropriate to split them up
rather quickly i've changed my mind i
think that the dual hat
with the unity of command it provides is
working very well for the current
and likely for uh future cybercom
commanders
now separating the two organizations
could create some real problems with
regard to the assets
that would have to be acquired in
addition to what we have today
would you please share your thoughts on
this with the committee
yes senator i don't have a position on
the ultimate disposition of the dual hat
arrangement for cyber common nsa um i do
have an assessment based on
my work on the transition team looking
at where we are
today and particularly in light of this
recent hack that included
exploitation of the solar winds
software and that is that we are not at
a maturation point now
with cybercom that makes the dual uh
hat arrange an end to the dual hat
arrangement wise
in the immediate um and if confirmed i
would be happy to continue of course
looking at this issue
and giving secretary austin my my best
advice
on um you know if there comes a point
where that does seem
to be the split does seem to be wise
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you senator rounds
via webex senator
irono thank you mr chairman
welcome dr hicks thank you for chatting
with me the other day
i start with the following two questions
of every nominee who comes before any of
the committees on which i
sit first question since you became an
adult have you
ever made unwanted requests or sexual
favors
or committed any verbal or physical
harassment
or assault over sexual nature no
have you ever faced discipline or
entered into a settlement related to
this kind of conduct no
i note in your responses to questions
from my colleagues that you
recognize the importance of the pacific
deterrence initiative
and that includes the importance of the
compacts that we have with the
freely associated states of micronesia
palau and marshall islands
i believe that we can do more in our
partnerships with them and i hope that
you will be open to
for example palau has asked us to invest
in joint use facilities such as
airfields and uh
well airfield so i hope that you'll be
open to doing more with our important
partners in the pacific
senator i am open to that
i do applaud secretary austin's recent
announcement that the pentagon will
prioritize climate change
considerations in its activities
risk assessments and in the next
national defense strategy
i believe that renewable energy is not
simply an environmental
calculation but it is becoming a
tactical necessity for the dod which is
the biggest user
of energy in our in our government
so we have included provisions in ndaa
to prioritize
energy security and resilience at
military installations
and i'd like to know whether you will
make energy resilience
and mission resilience and mission
assures a priority for the dod
yes senator i think uh the resiliency
aspects
on uh climate are critical as a business
proposition for dod
again focused really if you just take a
hard-nosed resource
look at it um and i want to commend
congress for re-establishing the
assistant secretary of defense for
energy installations and environment um
if confirmed i would work with senator
austin
excuse me secretary austin to ensure
that we uh put forward a nominee
who's uh very capable and competent in
these in these exact spaces
i think the issue of energy resilience
and
all of that is uh we have to see the
course uh senator shaheen had asked you
about the importance of our shipyards
and she said it's a parochial
concern but it is not it's it's i view
it as a national concern and of course i
chatted with you about the importance of
the four public shipyards of which
there's one in hawaii so the
modernization of these shipyards
is a very important concern for a number
of us and i hope that
i have your commitment that you will
continue to support
the funding for the modernization of our
shipyards
because it's as you acknowledge it's not
enough to just build ships we actually
have to
repair and maintain them yes i agree
completely
uh senator the sustainability of of all
of our forces frankly
especially if you look at where the cost
curves are on operations and sustainment
that's going to be vital if we're going
to compete effectively in the future
senator blumenthal and jill brown
have asked you questions about the
continuing scourge of sexual assault
harassment and i would include
retaliation on the basis of uh
reporting somebody who reports these
kinds of actions and
it continues to be a scourge as i
mentioned and every secretary every
deputy everybody who comes before us
from dod says that you will you will do
something about it so
i'd like to know you know what would be
uh measures of progress
in this area how would you determine
whether real progress is being made to
eliminate or or reduce the scourge of
sexual self-harassment and retaliation
senator i think first one of the most
important
tools we could have is transparency and
data
and i as you are likely aware
the department has not collected recent
data with regard to
reporting on sexual harassment
or we have we know how many
claims if you will have been made but we
don't know the totality of the reporting
if you look again at the fort hood
report if you look at that microcosm
of the fort hood community it was very
clear
it was significant under reporting
um underway and so i think that's an
area we'd want to look at right away
in terms of making clear that reporting
does not have uh negative consequences
for the career of
anyone in the total force civilians
contractors or military
um and that there are tools easy tools
hotlines that are easy to use that
everyone knows about that the training
is there
um and then i would just add sort of the
the training element a lot of these
um harassment harassment is often the
grooming process toward assault
us we have to look at both of those
issues and a lot of this is happening
in the the youngest of our service
members and
that means there's training
opportunities that means there's
leadership
opportunities at every uh level and
we need to be making sure we're holding
folks accountable at the same time we're
putting the resources into prevention
that's why it's important to have sexual
harassment as a separate charge
in these matters and maybe another way
to
determine the extent of the problem is
to pull your service members themselves
as to whether
they have experienced sexual harassment
assault
etc including by the way asking them
about
racial discrimination i believe my time
is up thank you mr chairman
thank you senator thank you senator rono
now via
webex senator tillis
thank you mr chairman and dr hicks thank
you for
being there i want to also thank you for
being so generous with your time on the
phone call last week we covered
a number of different topics i did want
to get back
to some of the discussion we had last
week particularly around
the on the one hand i like all the
responses you've given to my colleagues
on commitment to modernization
and our defense strategy on the other
hand
i think we're going to come up uh with
funding issues
and challenges to keep those programs on
track
so how do we when you go into this role
and i intend to support your
confirmation how do you
look at getting more productivity out of
the dollars we already have
in the face of the economic challenges
that we have
and maybe an administration that
wouldn't place the same priority on
funding that you've seen over the last
four years how do you get more
productivity
what kind of uh wide programs
think are appropriate to drive more
productivity for the dollars being spent
for senator thank you so much for um
your statement of support
and i enjoyed our conversation as well
um
let me let me tackle a few aspects of
that because it's a very
it's it's not an easy answer i think
some of the elements
are about tying the capabilities the
programs to capabilities to concepts
to what we're trying to achieve and that
concept to capability link
has been weak in the department for some
time again the department has some work
underway if confirmed i'd want to
get in in particular talk to the vice
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
about the status of that effort
and try to understand where the concepts
are driving us
to ideas about how we perform in the
field
against challengers that helps us really
focus the mind on the priorities we need
to have
in terms of what deters effectively what
creates credible
capability and also
you know where are there areas that are
lower risk there's never
a lack of risk the question is how to
prioritize effectively and be
transparent
about where we have decided to take risk
so that congress among others can can
make its own determinations
about those uh judgments i think the
other thing i would just point to is the
business operations side of dod i
mentioned
in my opening statement that that's an
area the deputy secretary
of course needs to be involved directly
in and it's in in large part for the
reason you point out which is
we have to make every dollar that the
taxpayer puts in
have a return and that return should be
measured in terms of joint capability
so that means we need to squeeze out um
obviously abuse but much more frequently
we see
waste um and that will be a priority for
me
um thank you dr hicks i think i
mentioned to you on the on the
call that we had that if i were there in
person i'd be bringing my
600 page plus rfp for the next
generation handgun
um i think that that's a case study and
an
acquisition process gone wrong so i've
had the bias that what we have to do is
go in and stratify
some of these acquisition processes that
are literally preventing some viable
suppliers from even participating
because they're so costly
and so time-consuming that uh we could
get a richer supply base i think if we
get smarter uncertain systems
clearly on more complex uh leading-edge
technologies it may take time but i
think all of them have to have an up and
down review
um dr hex i also just want to go back
and associate myself with
some of the comments made by senator
blumenthal and senator
gillibrand on military sexual assault i
suspect that that's going to be a
priority
in her position as chair of the
personnel subcommittee
and i'm very frustrated with some of the
confidence that i've placed in uh in the
department to make progress
and not seeing the kind of progress and
uh and i think
uh the foot fort hood review uh says a
lot needs to be acted on
the final question i have for you is
just your assessment
of our nato relationship and our
partners
what challenges or what can we build on
based on the prior administration
senator i think the u.s transatlantic
relationship
manifested most fully in in nato um
in the military sphere is is absolutely
vital to
any of the challenges we think of in the
future
even when we think about china as the
pacing challenge our relations with our
european allies
is critical to our effectiveness our
ability to build out a community of
democracies
that can counter authoritarian
approaches
so i see nato as a as a centerpiece
of our alliance networks throughout
throughout the world
um i i have been concerned i have
written on my concern that the focus on
burden sharing and we should always be
focused on burden sharing ensuring that
allies
fulfill their commitments but that when
it becomes that tactical issue the
overrides the strategic
value of the alliances alliances that
the chinese and russians could only hope
to match we have been
if we get to that point we have become a
strategic and i'm very hopeful that
president biden who has spoken
eloquently on this issue
will make good progress in returning
strategy to the center of our alliance
relations
thank you alex i look forward to working
with you thank you mr chair thank you
senator tillis senator
kane thank you mr chair and dr hicks
congratulations on your nomination
a couple of topics first on sexual
assault in the military when we
grappled with this issue in a major way
in 2013
and we've sort of been building upon
that since there were basically three
categories of
sask members there were those who felt
this problem was so serious
that the only solution to it was to
remove it from the chain of command
there were those who felt that the
problem was deeply serious and we needed
to make the chain of command work to
solve it
um and then there was a third group into
which i
senator king some others around the
table were in this group we knew it was
serious
we wanted to give the chain of of
command an opportunity to solve it
but if we were unhappy with results we
were very willing to go the
path of taking out of the chain of
command i just sort of want to put on
the record that that
third group of members of this committee
virtually all of us are really unhappy
with the
progress since 2013. we're now getting
to eight years
from then and we were willing to give
the chain of command new tools new
resources
new accountability mechanisms et cetera
et cetera et cetera
and we're not happy with the outcome and
so i think it's just important for the
pentagon community to know
that that was sort of a swing block in
2013 that led us to go down a particular
path
but many of us who were supporting those
um
within the chain of command improvements
have been very dissatisfied with the
results and we're now very open
to to
pursuing a different path as we said we
would at the time that's number one
uh number two here's an accomplishment
that is a
an obama and trump era accomplishment
that's also an accomplishment of
this committee and the pentagon pressure
for the pentagon finally to do an audit
like every other federal agency and to
have every function
of the pentagon and every part of the
pentagon audited
we did that because an audit is a good
oversight tool for this committee
an audit is a good accounting tool for
the numbers folks at the pentagon but we
also did it because an audit should be a
good management tool for folks like you
tell this committee how you will use the
audit in your
role should you be confirmed thank you
senator
my understanding um from the
team that's in the defense department
based on my work on transition
is that the audit in fact has been
useful as a tool of transparency
getting the data up and shared
and known first of all points directions
to some of these business process
improvements that we can
have but then even operationally it's
had the effect
of revealing inventory excess inventory
things of that sort
um that that not only again is efficient
but gets real capability out to the
field spare parts that
exist in inventory that are needed in
the field but
we didn't know we had them um so the
audit has revealed some of those very
basic
approaches as you say that every every
business
um has to um abide by and is advantaged
by
i think it is also pointed more
generally to the value of
data and as we move into
an era of data the department needs to
move there too
and the audit is showing the way to how
data can be
leveraged to make more sound analytic
decisions
i hope you'll continue that focus any
any dollar or
energy we spend on something unnecessary
or ineffective
is is a dollar that we're not spending
on these real challenges we have before
us
last question is this um there are
positions still to be named in the by
the administration
under secretary of defense for
acquisition and sustainment
and research and engineering many of the
nominees and appointments for dod spots
thus far are veterans of the obama
administration
local think tanks advocacy groups all of
which is important
but none thus far have extensive
acquisition or
industry experience the department was
well served in my opinion by some
previous officials like secretaries
lord gertz mccarthy who had sizable
acquisition experience before their
appointments
if confirmed do you have any sense of
where the department will look
to fill up the ranks of the a s and r e
portfolios so that we'll have
acquisition and research expertise in
the
a biden pentagon senator
um secretary austin when he was nominee
austin i spoke
quite a bit about those particular
positions and then of course you have
the the service acquisition executives
who have
increased responsibilities in the in
these areas
um and i know from secretary austin this
is among his highest priorities in terms
of
um positions to fill in the near term
um i i can't speak on his behalf about
the particulars of
of individuals but i can tell you that
the attributes i know
uh that the department
needs is that acquisition expertise
isn't familiar a familiarity with
the hardware and software ends of
where the department's capabilities are
coming from
and a really fine-tuned
sense of how to work in new ways with
industry to some of the issues that that
have already been raised
there are significant challenges to
non-traditional defense players getting
into the marketplace
we need to lower those if we're going to
compete successfully
thank you dr hicks thank you mr chair
thank you senator kaine senator sullivan
thank you mr chairman and dr hicks
congratulations on your nomination and
appreciated the opportunity to
chat uh the other day and i'm
really uh sorry i'm looking at my
my time here um appreci appreciate
your background
you